good afternoon CS 109 how are you guys
doing
today wo fantastic that's what I like to
hear happy Monday I hope you guys had a
fantastic weekend and you're excited to
come back and learn another great
concept cuz again we have a
fantastically important concept you guys
have probably heard about it before but
today you're going to learn all the
important details about it the normal
distribution which is one of the last
major random variables we're going to
talk about before we get into the next
level of cs19
like there's another level there's
always another level where we're going
to be talking about probabilistic models
um so let's enjoy this wonderful class
before I jump into things oh yeah um one
big announcement is that problem set
Three is out uh and problem set three is
going to be largely around random
variables uh in fact you the first set
of questions are using discret random
variables that you've already learned
about in the last few ones are using
continuous random variables uh which
were just finished finishing up our
conversation about
today I want to highlight a couple fun
things that you'll do you know back in
the day I used to teach random variables
and people would still find it confusing
and then once I introduce this problem
and it seems to crystallize so much to
different people what the different
random variables do in this problem
you're going to be writing code that
simulates each of the random variables
so you like simulate pulling a sample
from my binomial pulling a sample from
your geometric pulling a sample from Pon
and the process of simulating okay what
is bom it's a bunch of coin flips seems
to be very helpful for understanding
random variables um there's a lot of
problems where your answer should look
like Define a random variable tell me
its distribution write the question as a
probability statement and then solve a
whole bunch of your problems will have
that uh
template some of the cool things you're
going to do have you guys ever heard of
a bloom filter is this probabilistic
data structure that's using a whole
bunch of things like for example it's
used in Chrome to keep track of
malicious URLs and imagine how many
different URLs there are in the world
and putting all of them into a data
structure that says malicious or not
malicious that is incredibly difficult
thing to do but Google is able to do it
on every single one of your computers
using the thing called a bloom filter
wouldn't you like to learn more about
that yes yes yeah great you get to and
your problem set whether or not you want
to learn about it you're going to okay
and then um there's another interesting
question we actually got data from the
ipcc uh and made a whole problem around
it that is based on real predictions on
this thing called climate Sensi ensity
that's a very interesting random
variable climate sensitivity is a random
variable that says if you doubled CO2 in
the atmosphere what would be the
equilibrium state of temperature change
uh on planet Earth and so we're going to
be thinking about that very interesting
random variable on this problem set oh
and I love this problem maybe you guys
can just look at this no which of these
two sequences is
random they have the same number of
heads and tails but you have to go into
your investigative creative space in
order to answer this and speaking of
creative space one of my favorite things
on this problem is we're going to be
making some algorithmic art you'll make
some beautiful artwork like this uh
using a thing called a pretto
distribution what a fun time make some
artwork learn about some algorithms just
build this Foundation of random
variables I couldn't imagine a more fun
problem
set um and just a small note if you want
to learn more about the Predator
distribution don't forget that there is
a chapter about it inside the course
reader oh totally not important totally
not for grad but if you make some
beautiful artwork and you want to share
it with the class please do we would all
appreciate seeing the gorgeous artwork
that you
make okay cool that's what I've got
yes theine for I'm so glad you asked uh
so asked a very good question he's our
head uh he asked a very good question
when is the late deadline for problem
set three and that's such a good
question because problem set three goes
out
today and we want you to have finished
before the midterm which is basically in
two weeks from now because of that even
though the deadline for PR set 3 is not
this Friday but the Friday afterwards if
you gave yourself an extension it can't
go beyond that midterm so the longest
extension we give is actually only
Saturday Sunday and then Monday and a
half day so there's only a three and a
half days is the longest extension we'll
give for problem set three we want
everyone caught up on all their problem
sets by the time the midterm starts
thanks what a good question I really
appreciate it okay
fantastic now we are going to be
building off some of the great things we
talked about on Friday's class and since
it's been a weekend it's certainly worth
reviewing in Friday's class we started
with this simple observation that the
random variables we have have the
language to talk about the relationship
between values and the probability of
the random variable taking on those
values in the world of discreet random
variables where the answers are the
values are things like one two and three
this made a lot of sense but we got into
the continuous World it made a little
bit less sense and to give you that idea
let's say you had a random variable that
talked about the
height of babies when they're born and
maybe your your random variable you know
looks a little bit like this it it talks
about this is the most likely height
when babies are born and you know
there's a little bit of spread to
it if this was a discreet random
variable and he said like the height of
the baby is five you could talk about
the probability of that but it got
really really weird when you said what's
the probability of this baby that was
just born and you look at the baby's
weight it's a real value like what's the
you know weight of a baby let's say it's
10.12 134 and it's real valued so it's
going to keep
going you know if this is a whole number
we can talk about the probability of
random variable taking on a whole number
but how ridiculous is is it to talk
about the probability of a real valued
number that a random variable would take
on a real valued number so
continuous random variables present a
little bit of a
challenge to formalize that into
mathematics what we did on Friday is we
said okay let's imagine when a margarite
shows up and we had the first intuition
to just start by discretizing time we're
going to think about the continuous
random variable as time but we
discretized it to start out with we said
what if time was in five minute chunks
this makes it more look like a discret
random variable than a continuous random
variable but we could still solve
probability problems like what's the
chance that the bus shows up at this
point and then we said well we
discretized it into 5 minutes but we
could have discretized into more fine
grained elements and you can see where
this is going if you took those
discretizations and kept making more and
more fine grain event elements
eventually you would end up with a
smooth curve you get infinitely small
buckets and here the values wouldn't be
the probabilities and instead they would
be derivatives of probabilities that's
where we went on Friday what an
adventure do you guys remember Good
Times we'll be practicing that a little
bit today
okay we talked about a couple canonical
continuous random variables the easiest
one that we started out with was the
uniform random variable the uniform
random variable is such a good time it
basically says my random variable can
take on any value from A Min and a Max
here plotted is min0 Max one and it's
equally likely to take on any real
valued number between that range so it's
just as likely to take on the value 0.5
as 75 um and it gives you this nice
little
flat uh probability density function
fantastic we have things like
expectation and variance for it and but
what if you wanted to figure out the
probability of some range here so you've
got a probability density function how
do you figure out um a probability
question under that so what do you get
if you integrate over a probability
density function probility yay
probability that was exactly it you know
in the world of continuous random
variables that derivative of probability
we call the prob density function so as
you took time and you made it finer and
finer that thing you're left with we
call it the probability density function
or PDF and to get a probability answer
out of that PDF you would just find an
area under the curve and it was
equivalent to like as you discretize
time you were summing up uh columns and
this sum ended up becoming an integral
as we enter the world of
calculus but at the end of Friday's
class plot twist total plot twist we
were were working with continuous random
variables we had PDF we were doing a
bunch of integrals at the end of class I
like wait what if we could derive
something so we don't have to keep doing
a bunch of integrals and we introduce
you to the world of the CDF a CDF is
ideally a closed form equation for the
probability that a continuous random
variable is less than some number and if
you can Master using the CDF you can
solve a whole bunch of probability
questions without doing
integrals the example from Friday's
class was we said well let's say you had
this exp exponential random variable and
here's this probabbly density function
and you want to get the area under the
curve between 1 and two AKA you want to
know the probability of the random
variables between 1 and two you guys
were super clever and you came up with
this idea that we can look at the PDF
value at at two that'll give us the area
under the curve under two because that's
the probability that X is less than two
and we can subtract off the probability
that X is less than one and we figured
out a way to get the probability without
doing any integrals just two quick
lookups in this CDF you can derive the
CDF for um X itial someone has already
derived it for you if you want to know
and there you have
it that's a whole bunch of review what a
good
time
okay any questions before we jump
in let's go because it's an exciting and
big day we're going to be learning about
the normal distribution would you've
heard a bunch uh in your life and now
we're going to formalize it the normal
distribution is one of the most popular
random variables and it's a random
variable that describes a probability
density function that looks like this
and you guys have seen this before can I
just see some nods of heads if like just
to confirm confirm that sometime in high
school somebody has shown you a gaussian
distribution AKA normal okay that's a
good time a normal distribution has a
probably density function that looks
like this bell curve um is defined by
two things a mean and a variance the
mean kind of specifies what is the
middle of the be curve and the variance
specifies how wide is the bell curve
it's used for a whole bunch of things as
a random
variable we Define something to be a
normal random variable like this and as
I said there's two parameters the mean
that's the middle of the bell curve and
how wide it is that's the variance its
support is negative Infinity to Infinity
so technically you can answer probably
question about any value assignment to
X we call this the mean we call this the
variance its
expectation unsurprisingly is just that
parameter of the mean and it's variance
you guessed it is the parameter you gave
it so this is such an interesting random
variable it's a random variable you give
it the mean and you give it the variance
and then it gives you the rest of the
distribution and then finally this
random variable has a PDF and boy does
it have a PDF have you ever seen such a
beautiful equation it's such a beautiful
equation I wrote it up on the board over
here and this is the equation that
defines that bell curve that gives you
that shape that we all know live learn
and love uh the gaan distribution what a
beautiful equation we're going to use it
today that equation derive defines this
this is particularly where mean is zero
and Varian is one and if me is zero and
variance is one this beautiful set of
math describes that orange
curve now we're going to talk about the
gaussian distribution but it's worth
talking a little bit about this guy
Frederick Gus who you might have heard
of remarkably influential German
mathematician he did a whole bunch of
things um including invent or
popularizing the gaussian distribution
um but this is kind of interesting he
didn't invent the gaussian distribution
gaus isn't the inventor of it in fact
it's just that at some point in his life
he's like everybody you need to know
about this distribution it's so awesome
it's so useful for everything to the
point where he said that enough that
people were like okay we're just going
to call that thing the gaussian
distribution because he's like the
number one fan uh and I'm going to say
his celebrity looked like is a late
Robin
Williams but I've done something I don't
normally do in CS 109 normally I give
you a story and then we derive the math
but here I flipped it I just gave you
the math I said here's a gaussian
distribution here's the
math and the reason behind that is the
story for why gausin distribution is a
little bit nuanced can we talk about
this for a moment why do people care so
much about this gaussian
distribution one answer you might hear
is that it's very common for natural
phenomena like if you look at the
heights of babies when they're born they
tend to be gaussian if you look at the
weights of babies when they're born and
they tend to be gaussian all these
normal distrib or all these
distributions that show up in nature
seem to be
gaussian there's this argument that you
might hear that background radiation
noise and other forms of noise in
electronics often tend to be gaussian
that's similar to the first argument
natural phenomena seems to be
gaussian people might tell you if you
take a bunch of random variables and add
them up then that's what leads to a
gaussian uh and you might even hear an
argument something like the sample means
are distributed as a gaussian now notice
that gaussian and normal I use as
synonyms so if I say something's
gaussian and if I say something's normal
those are the exact same
claims okay let's go over each of these
that's kind of what they want you to
believe it turns out very few phenomena
in the real world are actually gaussian
a lot of them are very gaussian related
for example when people looked a little
bit deeper into Heights it seems like
maybe a log normal which is a related
distribution will be a better
fit now
most World noise in the world is normal
is a interesting claim but it also again
seems that most people just assume noise
is normal and it's some types of noise
we assume are normal but it's not
actually normal this sum of many random
variables we're going to go deeper into
when we get into our theoretical section
of Cs 109 but that turns out to only
apply when you're summing up equally
weighted and independent random
variables but if that they are equally
weighted independent turns out to be
gaussian uh and this fin one actually is
true but I want to give you the deeper
reason that you see gaussians everywhere
and this is a Christ opinion it's this
aam's razor claim that often the
simplest explanation is usually the best
one we're going to enter a next phas in
CS 109 where we'll do some problemistic
modeling where you have to come up with
what you think is the appropriate random
variable for something like a data set
and sometimes we don't know what the
right random variable is like for
example let's say you have a data set it
describes a single random variable and
when you get the histogram it looks a
little bit like this let's say nothing
about the story of this random variable
tells you what it is it doesn't tell you
it's a pan it doesn't tell you that it's
an exponential but you just have to
figure out what random variable it is
just by straight looking at
it complexity is very
tempting you might want to say okay I
don't know what this random variable is
so I'm going to define a brand new
random variable this is the Cris the
peach random variable the peach random
variable goes like this and it perfectly
describes my
data but you might not want to do that
because it kind of violates this idea of
aam's Razor that you should probably
give a simpler explanation to how the
world works and what people often do is
if they want to come up with a
generalizable solution they might want
to give you a simpler story and it turns
out one of the simplest stories you can
give is say I'm just going to assume
that this is gaussian it's probably not
perfectly gaussian but if I assume it's
gaussian I can calculate the mean I can
count the variance and I can tell the
world I think this is
gaussian that's generally accepted lots
of fields and science do this and it
turns that if you're curious there is a
deeper reason why that's a pretty
reasonable thing to do if you match the
mean and you match the variance and you
say I want to make as few assumptions as
possible beyond that there's a very
elegant mathematical proof that says
gaan is one of your Best Bets if you
want those two numbers to match if you
want to come with a random variable that
matches the match of the variance and
you choose a g skin it turns out this
claim is true it maximizes the entropy
of the distribution and the entropy is a
measure of disorder which is kind of a
measure of how little information uh
you've put into the Assumption you've
made wow that's a really really long way
of saying a pretty simple thing is that
many times gaussians will show up in
your life because people have assumed
gaussion because calcian is a pretty
reasonable assumption uh in lots of
cases when you don't know that much
about your random VAR
so so many things in the world are
assumed gaan that you absolutely need to
know them you need to know how to work
with them pretty well okay um entropy
we'll talk about it in office hours if
you're curious about it I'm super into
it uh but it's a little bit beyond CS
109 right now
okay but there's a final reason
gaussians are remarkably easy to use you
might see this equation and think that
they're hard to use but let me tell you
they are one of the nicer distributions
that I've worked with and a lot of times
when you're doing c s proofs if you can
make a gaan assumption a lot of cool
things fall out yes that's missing a
minus sign where in the
exponent minus 2 Oh e to the minus thank
you appreciate
it okay so my claim is that there's a
lot about this formula in some of the
rated formulas that actually make it a
little bit e easier to
use okay let's take a moment and do some
anatomy of this beautiful beautiful
equation because the Gan distribution
like once you've assumed it you
immediately inherit that this is the
probability density function it's got a
lot of moving pieces to it first of all
probability density functions are
functions where you put in an assignment
a possible assignment to your galin and
it gives you the derivative of
probability at that point so the input
is going to be a possible assignment to
your G
then you have this whole thing which
looks really complicated except most of
this is just a constant it's really cool
that there's a pi in there like
beautiful equation uh and it's got a pi
and an e what is this gorgeous equation
it's got all my favorite symbols in it
um this term over here says take that
query and see how far it is away from
the mean and it's going to be the square
of that difference so if you're into
Norms that's the L2 Norm um and then
here we have the variance showing up
twice so so it's like how far are you
from the norm somehow modulated by your
variance and that gives you your
density I don't know if I put the
equation in the top right can I show you
another way of writing that I think
highlights why it's easier to work with
this is the same equation but it's
written to look a little bit less
scary instead of writing e to the power
I use this exp which is what you write
in Python like if you want e to the
power something you do math. exp and exp
is the math thing which says e to the
power of this
uh and it just makes it a little bit
easier to read and you can see like oh
yeah that term is really the important
thing and it's not too scary of term
this thing which catches the I is
actually just one over Sigma times a
constant and sometimes when you times a
constant you can just write proportional
to because in lots of math the constant
will just fall away or if you needed it
it would just be two square root of 2 pi
that looks a little bit nicer okay
you're going to work with it you're
going to like it it's a good time
uh okay as I mentioned exp is something
you should know if you want ma mix math
and python um and proportional to is
certainly something that I hope you guys
saw in previous uh studies before CS
109 okay um I have this hypothetical
question what if you had to take the log
of this function like if for some reason
you found yourself doing a log so many
beautiful things would happen this would
become inition and the log of this
exponential would just cancel each other
out and You' just be left with this so
if you find yourself ever in the world
of logs and normals like little tears
well in your eyes because of the beauty
that happens okay I've been talking a
lot but you guys need to be practicing
your normal let's get your gaussian on
let's talk about how long it times takes
to travel between classes let's say you
measure how long it takes you to get
from class to or from home to class and
on average it's taking you four minutes
and from the data you collect you're
also able to estimate that the variance
is about 2 minutes squared or the
standard deviation is
um square root of 2
minutes we don't know the distribution
of how long it's going to take you it's
not coin flips uh it doesn't seem like
an exponential so let's say we're going
to say I'm going to suppose it's
normally distributed you've empirically
calculated the meum empirically
calculated the variance and now we're
going to assume that the whole
distribution is normal my question is
what if what is the probity you spend
more than 6 minutes traveling and that
means you're going to be late for class
and I want you guys to think about how
you would solve this problem uh and then
we're going to do it all together okay
so how do you solve this problem talk
about with the person next to you get
your gaussian
on okay I am going to interrupt you and
I'm I'm sure no one got to the end of
this yet
um because I wanted us to do it together
I'm glad that you guys had a chance to
think about it let's do this all
together the first step is to declare
your random variable as I said this is
going to become a pattern for you guys
to fill in you say like okay I'm going
to declare that X is not just any any
random variable it's a normal random
variable as soon as you write that then
you inherit the probability density
function that we've talked about and
particularly We Care what's the
probability that X is greater than equal
to 6 and we know that if you want to
know a probability with a random
variable you just integrate over that
range so this is 6 to Infinity you could
do 1 minus um 0 to 6 that would be fine
too well actually you'd have to do
technically negative Infinity one of the
awful things about this assumption that
travel time is gaussian is that gaussian
technically allows for to take negative
minutes to get to class like the Gans
defined over the entire range does that
make sense like it makes sense
mathematically but like does it make
sense for you to take negative minutes
to get to class not unless you're like
Hermon Granger otherwise it's going to
be taking positive minutes right anyways
aside from that bad assumption so
because Gans are defined in the rain to
Infinity we going to have to integrate
this from six to infinity and we're
going to integrate this beautiful
equation that says nice work with so
we're just going to do this integral um
and did anyone want to get the answer to
this
integral somebody think they did wol for
Alpha oh man okay so I told you at some
point in CS 109 like integrals they're
loving not scary except for this time
they're terribly scary it turns out
there's no closed answer to this
integral that was a cheeky question if
somebody did come up with the answer
please do see him after class and we'll
name the algorithm after you uh
certainly oh man wait how are we going
to do this we have a probably density
function but we can't even solve this
problem because we can't integrate under
this this is a non-integrable
function oh man we're to well this
gaussian seems useless yeah it looks
pretty but it can't do anything for us
because we can't integrate it ah we're
going to have to go back to the drawing
board do you guys want to go see how
you're going to do stuff like this yeah
we want to be able to do stuff with
gaans okay sad times let's just rally
ourselves and be like no we will will
not give up we will continue until we
figure out how to figure out the
probability that we're late for
class it turns out there's no closed
form for the integral and worse yet
there's no closed form for the CDF so in
the exponential we have this wonderful
CDF but there's no close form for that
either sorry can you just Define what do
you mean there's no CL form like closed
form would be able would mean that you'd
be able to write this integral as an
equation like you'd be able to write
down the answer to the integral like for
example like if I say x s
if you take that integral there is a
close form because you can write this
integral as an equation math that's a
very good question that's what I mean by
close form so there's no closed form for
the integral bummer worse there's no
closed form for the CDF total bummer but
question I don't know if this is like
within the scope of the class but why
does a function have a close form and
why does it not yeah let me see if I can
come up with a good example of something
that doesn't have a closed form
um
sorry yeah there's a bunch of things
where like the integral is not possible
to calculate where
it's maybe I I suppose in this one like
where did you get stuck it's like you
have to do break this up into parts and
there's no way to break this up into
parts so that you could write it down I
wonder if there's a deeper answer though
to like what are the family of things
that don't have close form integrals
I'll be curious about that but um long
story short if you try to work on this
which maybe it's worth spending five
minutes on and you try and say like okay
how do I integration by parts uh there's
no path that would lead to you be to
write down an
equation okay I'm going to give you the
end of the story and then we're going to
get there the end of the story which
I've written on the board because it's
important I want to have it in front of
us the whole time is that even though
there's no close form for the CDF
there's this magical function fi and
with this magical function fi I'm going
to give you a way to use a CDF for
gaussian does that sound good okay so at
the end of the class you'll understand
why this magical function f works and
you'll be able to use it to solve
problems it says that the CDF remember
the capital F is the cumulative density
function so the probability that your
random variable is less than Little X is
equal to this numerically calculated
thing called fi and F is going to be a
function where you put in the difference
between the input to your CDF the mean
of the gaan and you're going to
normalize it by the standard
deviation but to get to that final
conclusion that there is this CDF that
we will be able to use you need to know
some of the beautiful properties of
normals and that will lead us to be able
to drive this the first cool thing about
a normal is that if you transform the
normal a little bit you'll still end up
with a normal and by transform the
normal let me give you an example of
what I mean mean we have a normal up
here and let's say I say that was our
normal of time to get to class Y is
equal to the normal of the time to get
to class plus I always take three
minutes for my shower so the amount of
time from the start of my shower to when
I got to class is y and that's take my
normal and add a number that's called a
linear transform because I'm just adding
number even if I said like some constant
multiplied by X and then added that's
still a linear transform and a beautiful
thing is if x is a gaussian any linear
transform you do will lead to another
gaussian
good times so not only that we can
calculate exactly what gaussian it is we
can calculate what gaussian it is
because we can figure out what's the
expectation of this new gaussian and the
expectation of the new gaussian is just
going to be the expectation of what Y is
equal to but because expectation itself
is linear this whole thing works out to
be pretty
straightforward now
variance is not exactly linear if you
say x is a random variable if you do do
ax plus b it turns out that the variance
of this transformation drops the plus
that doesn't change variance at all but
any multiple times x has a squared
effects on variance so if Y is equal to
ax plus b then the variance of Y is
equal to a^2 * the variance of
X and this means that if you do this
linear transform any lary transform you
want it will be a normal and I will know
exactly what normal it will be it will
be the normal with this mean and this
variance okay that's kind of
cute but it turns out it gets a little
bit cuter so what we have derived so far
is that if you do a linear transform the
result is going to be normal what I'm
going to now show you is a very magical
linear transform give me any normal like
for example this normal and I can
transform it to be the normal with mean
zero and variance one you guys ready for
it okay
if you
choose particularly you're going to take
your random variable if you multiply by
one over the standard deviation and then
you subtract off this number that's a
linear transform do you guys believe me
it's a linear
transform we must have trust before we
go
on so X is a random variable this is a
linear transform and it turns out I
chose a very special linear transform
because when you do this no matter what
random variable you started with it will
transform it into normal with mean z and
variance
one so to convince you of this you know
this linear transform the multip the
multiple is one over Sigma and the
addition term is negative mu over
Sigma and we can put those equations
into here we can say like if we did this
linear transform with this a and this B
what will this result in well let's try
it out let's plug and chug we're going
to plug in that for a and that for B and
if you plug it in here's what you get in
the first term you get a * mu is going
to be mu over Sigma and then plus b is
going to be negative mu over Sigma hey
look what happens to these terms Tada
there's zero what happened when we plug
in you know one over Sigma for a you get
one over Sigma squ time Sigma squ hey
guess what happens here you get
one no matter what normal you gave me
like if you gave me this normal I could
choose a is equal to 1 / 2 cuz that's 1/
Sigma 2 and I can choose B is equal
to-4
/ < TK 24 over < tk2 and if I use that
particular a and that particular B if I
did ax plus b I would end up with a
normal with mean zero in variance one so
far this is just cute you're like hey
that's cute you take any normal and you
can transform it into the standard
normal but it turns out it's a little
bit more than cute because the standard
normal is something that we could do a
lot of computations on ah everybody
Welcome the standard normal it's like
the chillest of the chill distributions
if the normal is the the the least
entropic distribution that matches mean
and variance the standard normal is the
most relaxed version it has the simplest
values of the prameters mean is zero
variance is equal to one mean is zero
means it's will have its peak at zero
and one means it just won't be that uh
thin it won't be that
wide what people did these crazy folks
is they got their computers out and they
said what if we calculate the CDF for
the standard normal we can't do the CDF
for all um normals but we can do it for
the standard normal we can get a whole
bunch of computers and just try and do
some numerical integration and using
some numerical integration we could come
up with a big lookup table and that big
lookup table will have the CDF of the
standard
normal and they did that and the world
has never been the same sense uh because
it allowed us to do a whole bunch of
other things now
particularly there when they did this
numerical calculation they ended up a
big lookup table where you could put in
something like
1.3 and it would return you back this
CDF of the standard normal at 1.3 and
they called this lookup table
five so what are the two pieces we've
got you can take any normal and make it
look like the standard normal and people
have made a big lookup table for the CDF
of the standard normal we got those two
pieces what we would like to have is for
any normal distribution to know it's
CDF but we can put these two pieces
together like a delicious peanut butter
and jelly sandwich to come up with a CDF
for any normal distribution before I do
that though any questions on fi which is
the CDF of not any normal noral just a
standard
normal yes um what's the point of
converence to have mean Zer and variance
one if say we have a problem where in
fact mean score like I feel like just
losing information you're totally right
okay so um you're you know right now
we're doing all this work for mean zero
and variance one and so far that's doing
nothing for our problem here which has
mean four and variance 2 there this is
like lost information it's this whole
calculation is done with the wrong
parameters we want the right parameters
so you're right the tension is right I
just haven't given you the answer okay
so when you say Z is kind of like n with
m z Etc what does that Tilda basically
indicate this one yeah like conceptually
what does it mean to say that they're
similar oh it's not similar this is is
distributed as whenever you see the til
in cs19 it means is distributed as so X
is distributed as a normal and this is
saying Z is distributed as a normal so
that tiled doesn't mean approximately it
means is distributed as good question
because in a lot of other places til is
used for
approximation
okay here is what fi looks like you can
print it out people used to print it out
actually when I took CS 109 the teacher
gave me a print out of f is like here
you go people did all this work it's on
a piece of paper and I could hold it and
love it but that was actually quite
useless uh because now computers can
store it too but this piece of paper
just had the whole numeric
pre-computation for five so you could be
like hey five of 1.13 you could look it
up on this piece of paper and know that
it's
0.90 and that five recall CDF of the
normal saying so if you have a standard
normal the likelihood that its value is
less than 1.31 is
949 okay couple things that are cute
about F though it's symmetric so if you
ask a fi of a negative number that's
equivalent to asking the FI or one minus
the FI of a positive number
um if you do if you just want to know
the likelihood that your standard normal
is between C and D just like we did with
cdfs before you can do the CDF at D
subtract out the CDF at C there's a
whole bunch of cute things you can do
with
f okay but this is like Beyond cute it
turns out we can use fi to figure out
the CDF of any
normal you guys want to see how we're
going to figure out this by transforming
any normal into the standard
normal here's what we're going to do
let's say F ofx is for not the standard
normal but rather a normal we care about
say how long it takes to get to
class we can take our X and we've got
the probability of this U binomial or
sorry this Boolean expression and I'm
going to subtract mu from both
sides If I subtract mu from both sides
you know since mu is a constant this is
a still a valid inequality do you guys
agree and next I'm going to divide
standard deviation from both sides
that's a fair thing you can do with the
left hand side since this is a constant
you can divide now I note that variance
is always or sorry standard deviation is
always positive you can't have a
negative standard deviation and you have
to be careful when you divide in a less
than sign if you could have a negative
number but since this is a positive
number this is still something valid we
can
do but the interesting thing about this
is over here we have a number this is a
number minus a number divide by a number
over here we have a random variable it's
a random variable minus a number divide
by number and it turns out this is in
fact a linear transform and it's not
just any linear transform notice that
over here what I've done is the linear
transform that is z if you take any
random variable and you subtract off its
mean you divide by its standard
deviation that was the transformation
that we were doing to get Z so when I
did this transformation to this random
variable I was left with
z and that's kind of cool the
probability that any normal is less than
or equal to X is the same as asking
what's the probability that the standard
normal is less than or equal to x - mu
divide by standard deviation where these
are the two parameters of
x w that's super cool why is that super
cool because now we're answering the
question of X in terms of Z and we
already know it's the probability that Z
is less than something that was just
five the probability that Z is less than
some number is five of whatever that
number is and that's how we get this
equation if you have any gaum
distribution and you want to know what's
the probability that is less than a
little X you take that little X you
subtract the mean divide by the standard
deviation take that number put it
through five which is the CDF of the
standard normal and that will give you
the CDF of your normal
and we've learned so many things along
the way like what a beautiful Journey it
led to this really useful formula but
along the way we learned what F was we
learned that you can transform a normal
distribution and it'll lead to another
distribution like what a beautiful
Journey we've been on but this is really
where it ends so if we go back to this
problem what's the probability that X is
greater than equal to 6 now how would
you solve
it again talk to the person next to you
let's see if we can actually come up
with a way to get a number answer
here
okay I started up here I said hey what's
the probability that X is greater than
equal to 6 I don't like greater than
equals because the CDF is always saying
the probability that your random
variable is less than number so whenever
I have continuous things and I've got a
probability that's greater than I try
and convert it into probability that's
less than and this is true the probity X
is greater than equal 6 is equal to 1us
the probability X is less than 6 and I
did that transformation because this is
what a CDF is telling you this is saying
what's the CDF at six CDF is the capital
F sometimes you write the random
variable you care about as a subscript
so it's the CDF of our random variable
six at sorry random variable X at the
value six and now we just need to know
what's the CDF of a normal but we've got
it over here it uses this fi which is
that cool little
thing uh this is equal to 1us 5
of X in this case is 6 minus the mean o
where's the mean whose mean what mean is
it standard normals mean where the mean
come from just yell it out which mean do
I
mean oh how cute was that I said mean
twice okay and then what's the standard
deviation that I should be plugging in
here square root of two yes don't get
confused variance is often what's given
as a parameter for the normal but this
function wants the standard deviation
which is a square root of variance uh
and this is equal to 1 - 5 of 2 / < TK
of
2 this would be a whole number you could
get your lookup table but that lookup
table also exists in your computer and
actually one of the places it lifts is I
made this calculator section in the
course reader uh and you know there's a
fi so you can put in like two in here
and it'll tell you the FI table for two
so that's the probability that a
standard normal is less than two you can
do 0.05 we you know this is not that
important right now but anyways we could
get two divide by square otk two put
into our five calculator and just one
minus that will be our answer question
is there a liit to the
Precision oh yeah you know there is that
tells you something deep there's a limit
to the Precision about probably
questions we can ask about gausset but
it's done in a
computer and you know how it's done it's
done using this really cool thing called
Monte Carlo sampling which again we can
talk about offline uh but allows it to
have the Precision that you expect from
a computer that can go really really
precise and because so many things use
gaussians they spent a lot of time
making this a very very very precise
lookup table so good question yes look
table is there anything different asking
like proba X is less than 6 versus X is
less than or equal to 6 oh that's such a
good question I'm really glad you asked
it so the question is what's the
difference probably X is less than equal
to six so here's my interesting thing so
your question is what's the difference
between probably X is less than equal to
six and the probably that X is equal to
or sorry less than six did I get that
right so do you agree that this is true
you buy this okay let me blow all our
minds this equals
zero wait
what no matter what value you have the
probability that a continuous random
variable takes on exactly that value is
zero think about the baby and the baby
being born with like 10.6 1 2 3 4 5 6
like infinite Precision the probability
of that infinite Precision number is
zero the probability of any exact query
is zero and it's only area under a range
that leads to non-zero probabilities so
isn't that kind of cool fun little side
question I hope it gives some insight to
some people okay oh you guys are asking
this quarter I'm getting such good
questions and I really appreciate keep
it up
everyone okay man this leads to the
number one takeaway for today if you're
working with a normal distribution very
likely you'll want to know probability
questions and you're going to use the
CDF of a normal the CDF of the normal
uses this fi trans this fi lookup table
um and this transform to the standard
normal uh to solve
problems okay and here we are the end of
our journey we have the CDF of a normal
distribution and you can just use this
equation okay as I said looking up in
the table is kind of old school if you
wanted to there is this thing called
stats. norm. CDF that will allow you to
do this lookup much faster and again you
can also just use the course reader if
you wanted to it is kind of interesting
though I didn't want to point out this
thing that I don't normally point out
but I think it's
cool this is fi as a function right fi
as a function you can put it in a number
and you'll get a probability out it's a
onetoone function so you can invert it
you can say hey if I have 0
705 what input leads to that
number and you might want to use that at
some point you can you can always do the
inverse of five you can the inverse of
five
says what probability do I put in here
that will give me back some
number uh
oh did I get that sorry you put in
your no yeah yeah you put in your
probability and you get back a number I
just wanted to note that it's an
invertible
function
okay in the course reader okay back to
the campus bikes we can't do it using an
integral but we can do the transform and
if you did the transform you know you
would get this which you can then put
into the five table and you get that the
probability that you'll be late is only
8% you can decide if that's a decision
or a risk you're willing to take on your
way to
class okay let's do a little bit of
getting your gaing on some people
suggested that we do more examples and I
wanted to just give you a whole of
examples so here's a new gaussian it
could mean anything but let's just solve
some problems with it so standard
deviation is four because the variance
is equal to 16 and the mean is three I
put um over here that most important
formula that you might want what's the
probability that this Gan is greater
than
zero well if you want to know the
probability that it's greater than
zero you would just
do probably is greater than equals 1
oneus the probability that's less than
zero and one minus probability less than
zero is going to be equal
to so it's greater than Z equal 1 minus
the probability that it X is less than
zero uh is 1us 5 of 0 minus the mean ID
by standard deviation in this case oh
the standard deviation in this case we
know that the standard deviation is
equal to four and the mean is equal to 3
0 - 3 is going to be just three and
you'll get five of
-3 or 4 and you do one minus that that
will be your
probability okay if you want to know the
probability that 2 is less than x is
less than five so you want to do AR
range how would we do that and think
about it for a second and then we'll do
it all together I'm going to give you
guys uh 30 seconds to think about this
or come up with a question for the
class okay any questions come up
people are curious about I mean the key
here is to realize that this inequality
can be broken down to the probably X is
less than 5 minus the probably that X is
less than two it's the same thing that
we did with the exponential distribution
last Friday so you know that can be the
probably X is sorry X is less than 5
minus probably X is less than two and
both of these are just plugging into the
CDF of
X okay and then finally what's the
probability that X absolute value or x -
3 absolute value is greater than six wow
you never seen an asle value are you
allowed to do that oh yeah you are
allowed to do that uhoh question um
thinking back to that bike problem right
when you're looking at a CDF that right
less than two let's say you put in any
number doesn't it take into account the
positive values that you have a negative
time so isn't that a little off or can
can we like end the CDF at zero okay so
the question kind of comes back to this
by problem and you're annoyed by this
really awful thing about our assumption
so if this is zero so this is X is zero
the gaan has a mean of four and then it
has a variance of two which means it's
going to kind of look like this
right something like that but it's going
to have all these nonzero values less
than zero like there is some probability
if you ask what's the probability of
taking less than zero minutes to get to
class you can put it into your standard
normal and you get a positive number
back and you're saying is there a way to
not do that cuz that seems dumb uh yeah
there is you could there's two solutions
one is you could calculate the
probability less than zero and you can
somehow just subtract that
off the more elegant thing to do is to
realize if you subtract off this you
kind of need to increase the probability
mass of the rest of the thing so that it
still integrates to to zero and then
you've invented this thing called a
folded normal and there's a thing called
a fold normal and that kind of like
deals with the fact that sometimes you
want normals that can't go negative um
and you know we can talk about that
offline very cool question what we can't
talk about offline what we have to talk
about online is what happens when you in
absolute value you're like oh man
absolute values that seems
complicated the idea here is to realize
that this absolute value is actually
making two different claims there's two
different cases that satisfy this
absolute value if x is less than -3 so
if you put in like5 into
here5 - 3 will be8 take the absolute
value that's greater than 6 and any
value less than -3 will make this
equation true similarly any value
greater than n so 10 minus 3 will be
7even that's greater than six any value
greater than n will also make this true
and once you realize that this absolute
value equation is actually just one of
these two mutually exclusive
cases then now you can figure out your
probability just by doing cdfs again
this is the CDF of your random variable
at -3 and this is 1 minus your CDF F at
9 uh and there you have it you can put
in the five CDF equation for both these
uh you could put into a calculator if
you want to and eventually you get
okay which leads me to this moment where
actually I want to take a pedagogical
pause because what we've talked about so
far is really important we've talked
about normal distribution and at this
point I hope you guys have mechanics to
work with the normal distribution you
either have the relative likelihood or
you have the probably that your random
variable is less than some number Take 2
minutes think about it before we get on
to other cool things you can do with
normals cuz there's a lot okay take your
moment how to work with a
normal but it turns out the normal is
useful in many many other cases and I
want to give you an idea of some of that
breadth so I want to start by an imagine
situation and I want want you guys to
put on your like hacki as hats and
you're going to try and make it through
this tough situation I'm going to
present you with the tough situation I'm
going to present you with is imagine
you're doing an exam and this question
shows up 100 people are given a new
website design X is going to be the
number of people whose time on the site
increases the CEO is going to endorse
your due design if you know if you try
this on 100 people if more than 65 have
more time on the site than the CEO is
going to endorse it
my question is what's the probability
that the CEO endorses your change given
it has no
effect well if it has no effect the
number of people who are going to spend
more time on your site is going to be
binomial there's 100 people and everyone
has a 50/50 chance of spending more time
or less time uh because it has no
effect so this is a straightforward
binomial question where you're given a
binomial distribution and you want to
calculate the probability that your
binomial is greater than equal to
65 but then you're sitting down for an
exam and it says this give a numerical
answer and you're like uh what you can
write down your binomial probability
Mass function a remember that back in
the day and then you can sum that from
the value 65 to 100 and you can plug in
all those numbers add it up and that
should be the probability that X is
greater than equal 65 and you write this
down you're like that's some partial
credit and partial credit is a thing um
but then it ask for the numerical
answer and you're feeling like ah I
really want to get a little bit more
partial credit got a little bit more
time what could I possibly
do I'm I'm actually going to jump into
the Insight you have you're like first
of all we are always presented with
moments like this we like I don't know
the answer and it's like certainly the
most important thing might be to find
one Zen you're like ah you know what I
might not do the answer but I'm going to
try anyways that's the Stanford
way and you go back in your mind and you
recall this moment in class when you're
learning the binom bomal and we were
learning the binomial we had this
wonderful gon board where we threw all
these balls down these pins and because
of the binomial distribution we could
predict exactly how many balls would end
up in how many bins and in this hacki of
hacky moments you're like you know what
that kind of looks like a normal
distribution and if I had a normal
distribution getting numerical answers
is a lot easier uh because I can use my
fi lookup table um what if I got super
hacky and I took that binomial
distribution and I approximated I just
tried to draw like the best markered
normal over this
binomial so that we could try and come
up with a numerical answer how hacky
does that sound so hacky we should just
try it okay so you know you might want
to solve this it turns out if you were
to solve this correctly you get the
answer
0.018 but we don't have time for that
it's on the exam they want a numerical
answer approach number two and you know
let's say you don't have a calculator
that is an important detail here
approach number two the hacky approach
is we're just going to draw a gaussian
and hope it looks like our binomial how
hacky does that sound so I'm going to
Define why to be this hacky normal that
looks a lot like the binomial it's going
to have a particular mean and a
particular variance and that's our first
task as the people who are just guessing
and trying to get some partial credit we
have to say what mean and variance would
lead to a pretty good guess for matching
this binomial
and you sit there and you're like okay
okay I'm feeling the creativity and then
it hits you you should like oh binomials
have known expressions for means and
variances those are equations we've got
if somebody tells you the binomial you
can use a plug-in equation to figure out
the mean it's actually just n * p and
there's also an equation for the
variance of binomial it's n * P * 1
minus P what if we chose a normal that
just match those two statistics so we're
going to put the expectation of our
binomial that's n * p and we're going to
put in the variance of our bomal it's n
* P * 1 - p uh so this is 50 and 50 * .5
is
25 so you're like okay I'm going to say
why is that particular normal and now
I'm going to say the probability that X
is greater than equal 65 is pretty much
the probability that Y is greater than
equal
65 and the probity that Y is greater
than 65 is 1 minus the CDF of Y at 65
and we now know what to do with that you
just put it into this formula you take
65 subtract off its mean you divide by
its standard deviation you get a number
which you put into the file lookup table
and you get
0.0013 and the person grading you is
like wow that's a whole bunch of extra
credit or partial credit you got really
really close you know it's not exactly
the right answer the right answer is
0.18 and you got
0.0013 but you're getting
there and you're like oh why didn't I
get it perfect is it because this was
super hacky and the Galaxy and the
binomial are two separate things and you
just made it sound like they're the same
thing it turns out
actually it wasn't such a crazy thing to
do after all but you did miss one
thing here is a binomial with mual 100
and variance equal to 0.5 and here is
the matching normal that you defined
look how nice a match that is is that
not
elegant like that was a good choice I
applaud us on our choice uh we actually
though did make a mistake and I want to
zoom into this section of the graph to
talk about this
mistake here's the binomial in blue
here's the probility of 64 here's a
probably 65 here's a probability of 66
we were supposed to be asking what's the
probability that X is greater than 65
and so we put 65 into our normal and we
got all of this
area but we were supposed to include
this whole rectangle and we kind of
chopped the rectangle and half do you
guys see how we did that we only
included this half the rectangle we
didn't include that half and so there's
a whole bunch of things in this
rectangle that we didn't approximate
very well if we really wanted to be
super hacky and legit we should have
actually just bumped up this by half a
point so that we would have gotten that
whole rectangle because we're supposed
to getting the probability of less than
or equal to 65 which is supposed to
include this rectangle that red line
should be moved over by half a
point if you move that red line over by
half a point uh so uh probably Y is
greater than oh greater than or equal to
65 ah sorry sorry sorry we want greater
than or equal to we wanted all the dark
blue which means we need to shift the
red line over by half point this way if
we said Y is greater than equal 64.5 so
we shift the red line over half a step
so that you know we take advantage of
the fact that we're supposed to include
this entire
column if you asked this question of why
you would have gotten exactly the right
answer and in fact the reason we didn't
get the right answer wasn't because the
normal is a bad approximation of the
binomial the reason we didn't get the
right answer is simply because we didn't
do this little bit complicated
continuity
correction so it turns out major
takeaway you can approximate a binomial
which is hard to calculate with a normal
and a normal is very easy to calculate
in lots of situations we'll talk about
when this is valid but if you do so
you're approximating a discrete
distribution using continuous one and
that means when you ask a probability
question question you have to be super
careful to think about the correction
from when you go from the discret world
to The Continuous World um I have
written down a whole bunch of these
Corrections if your discret question
about X is probably that x equals 6 in
the continuous world to capture that
whole rectangle you should do y between
5.5 and 6.5 that will capture the whole
rectangle of x equals 6 if you want the
probity X is greater than six well
that's the same as probably Y is greater
than equal 5.5 that allows you to
capture the six rectangle and again
these are all the different times when
you either don't need to include the six
rangle or you do need to include the six
rectangle anyways there's all these
continuity Corrections so you can
approximate but when you approximate you
have to do a little bit of adding half a
step to make sure that the probability
question that you ask is the appropriate
one for the comparison that tables in
your reader you're going to practice it
a little bit and that's better done when
you do you're
practicing this leads us to an
interesting situation binomials are hard
to calculate we now have two ways to
approximate them earlier in class we
learned that pan now we've learned about
the normal who gets to approximate well
here's an example of binomial with
10.04 in this case you can see you know
both the pan or the Pan here is kind of
a better
approximation here's a binomial where
the MU or sorry the N is much larger and
the p is much more moderate and here if
you look this gray Line's not a very
good match but the orange line which is
the or the normal is a very good match
basically the plon approximation is
really good when these two categories
hold n is large p is small and the
normal approximation is great when n is
large and the variance is also large and
so if you calculate the variance if
that's larger than 10 you can use normal
approximation and this shows up all the
time if there's a choice either is fine
um and when you're using the normal you
have to do the continuity correction the
pon doesn't need it because the pon
already discreet the normal is the
continuous
one okay and here's is a question to
practice that this is a real question
that Stanford thinks about all the time
so you know Stanford has a fixed number
of dorms when they admit students they
admit people not knowing if they'll come
to Stanford and in their Ideal World
they admit the perfect number of
students so that the people who say yes
is equal to their number of freshman
dorms is there anyone here who's living
in a freshman dorm actually can anyone
tell me are we overflowing on freshman
dorms like are there freshmen who are
living on off-campus do you guys know
that happened evgr is happening no evgr
a a they maybe try underground healing
too so they can yeah man Stanford always
has this problem where like too many
people come and they have to like once
when I was an undergraduate they put
them in like a hotel across the street
The Freshman were living was a total
disaster now they should be thinking I
don't know if they're thinking about
probabilistically but they should be
thinking about probabilistically so
let's think about it for Stanford so
let's say Stanford accepts 2,480
students every student may come or they
may not come and Stanford thinks that
the probability that they come is like
and if the probability is 68 let's say x
is the number of students who will
attend how could you answer a question
like what's the probably that X is
greater than 1745 where imagine 1745 is
the number of available dorms so if more
than 1745 people come then they don't
have enough dorms for everybody if they
ask for an actual number there's a few
ways you can answer this you could solve
this using a binomial every students a
coin flip 6 probability of being heads
and we want to know the total number of
heads that's not wrong but but it's hard
to calculate so you could approximate as
a pan it turns out pan is a bad choice
here though cuz pan really wants P to be
very tiny to be a good approximation and
68 is not tiny P wants to be like 05 or
something smaller than that the normal
approximation though turns out is a very
good choice and if you actually sat down
and calculated the variance it'd be 540
so 540 is a lot larger than 10 that was
our requirement and also n is pretty
large 2,480 we want a large n and a
moderate variance or sorry a large
variance so this is a binomial question
but it's one where a normal
approximation would just make things a
lot easier so we're going to Define
approximating normal say why is similar
to the binomial we care about its
expectation is n * P because that's the
expectation of variance and it's
variance equals n * P * 1 P because
that's the variance of binomial and we
can calculate both of those numbers and
we can say now we know that y or sorry
um sorry Y is going to be our
approximating normal the probability
that X is greater than
1745 we're going to do a continuity
correction say that's about the same as
asking what's the probity that the
approximating normal is greater than
equal to
17455 now we can just solve this you
know the probability that a normal is
greater than a number it's something
that we've done a whole bunch in today's
class you just use the CDF so or one
minus the CDF in this case and you just
plug into the CDF you take in the input
you put to the CDF subtract off the gy
mean divide by the Gan standard
deviation and you get a number so in
this case Stanford would feel like hey
if we accepted 20480 students students
there's a
0.0055 chance that we won't
overflow fun fact these are real numbers
from a real year uh and then they wrote
an actual article because it turned out
to be a total disaster they assumed the
yield rate would be like 65 and that
year the yield rate was like 82% which
mean 82% of people were saying yes and
they're like putting people people in
hotel rooms fun things okay we've
already done our pedagogic B but anyways
binomial you can approximate it with a
gaan I thought that's where we' end but
we have some time and I've gotten some
super cool or there's so many cool
questions about normal and I want to
just start showing you a couple more you
guys want to see more
examples this was a cool question that I
got asked by a student have you guys
ever heard of the 68% rule fun fact
about all gaussians 68% of its
probability Mass exists within one
standard deviation of the mean always
and
exactly so what that means is if you
take any gin with a mean in a variance
if you figure out what's the probability
that the random variable is between one
standard deviation greater than mean and
one standard deviation less that
probability is always
68% and the question was is this only
true for normal distributions or is this
true for all distributions well first of
all let me convince you it's true for
normal
distributions so what's the probability
that the distance between your random
variable and the mean is less than the
variance which is really saying what's
the probability that your random
variable takes some value between this
number and this number we've already
broken that up in an earlier problem
that's the same as the CDF of the larger
number minus the CDF of the smaller
number so what's the CDF of any random
variable any gaan with a mean mu and
standard deviation Sigma evaluate at
these
points recall that this is now the input
to the CDF this is X so if you take that
X and subtract off the mean divide by
the standard deviation it actually
simplifies to just one because here when
you take this and subtract off the mean
those means cancel and then the standard
deviations cancel and you're left with
one something similar happens on this
side and you're left with five of
negative 1 you might look at this and be
like uhoh are these two things going to
cancel and you're left with the
probability of zero they don't cancel
because five of a negative number uh is
equal to 1 minus 5 of the positive
number so you know if you put in a
negative 1 into five that's the same as
doing 1us
51 if you figure this out if you kept
going which you could do using a
calculator or you can just use your five
table it ends up that there the
probability that for any gussian the
random variable takes on the value in
this range is in fact equal to not 68
but
6826 we didn't put in hard numbers for
mean we didn't put in hard numbers for
variance and we got this number so
whatever your gy is turns out 68% is
within one standard deviation does this
apply for
uniforms just Instinct who thinks that
68% of a uniforms probability will occur
within one standard deviation of its
mean who thinks
nah but why not let's show okay if this
is a uniform what's the probability that
it's within one standard deviation of
this mean exact same
formula um but now what's the
probability that the random variable is
in this range notice in a uniform if you
have a range and you want to find the
area under the curve what shape is that
area under a curve rectangle it's a
rectangle so we can skip all the calcul
and be like what is the area of this
rectangle it's got a width and it's got
a height the height is equal to the CDF
of the uniform and the width here is
just equal to the larger Point minus the
smaller point and that's the area of the
rectangle and if you solve for this you
know um you just reduce you end up with
for a
uniform
0.58% of its probably Mass within did
you guys ever know the 58% rule 58% rule
for uniform that 58% of its problem Mass
within one standard now you know it's
not that
important gaussians show up
everywhere here's another cool extension
idea did you know that gaans are used
for for a lot of sports they originally
were used in chess but they've shown up
in all other sports like basketball so
if you want to say what's the
probability that the Warriors win a
particular game I know we talked about a
serious series before but if you want to
talk about a particular game a lot of
people use this thing called an ELO
rating and an ELO calculation which
involves
gaussians here's how elos work you might
have heard about them because they've
showed up in a lot of places every team
has an ELO score and it's based on its
past
performance um and we think of that
score as being the mean of a normal
distribution when they play a game they
sample from this mean that's how they
play on average but sometimes they play
better and sometimes they play worse we
think a team wins when the probability
when sorry when their ability is greater
than the other team's ability invented
by this guy called rped ELO and it looks
like this it's saying the Warriors you
know based on their past performance
they have a mean performance of
1657 but when they show up to play they
might play Above their mean or they
might play below their mean and their
ability when they show up on a
particular night will be governed by
this
gaussian the opponents will also have an
ELO rating and that ELO rating will be
the mean of gaan with the exact same
variance they set this per sport in
ELO's
world and you know when you show up you
might outperform your mean and you might
underperform your mean but every team is
going to get an AB ility on a given
night and whoever's ability is larger
wins now actually this is kind of awful
or I don't know if we should put a value
judgment ELO rating showed up in chess
then they transferred to sports I don't
know if you know this for the longest
time this app called Tinder was using
ELO ratings to figure out how they were
going to be giving matches which like a
whole awful conversation we could have
about that but anyways the important
thing is Warriors have a good
probability of winning in this game and
let's talk about exactly what that prob
this is an interesting
thing a is this gaussian AO is this
gaussian for the opponent's ability and
I want to know what's the probability
that this random variable is greater
than this random
variable that's so different than asking
the probability that a random variable
is greater than a number you know up
till now it's been a random variable and
a number and now I've got two random
variables on either
side oh I promise when we get to Theory
section we'll talk about exactly how you
could solve this uh with a closed
formula but I also want to show you
something that we often do with random
variables as computer scientists how
would you solve this if I didn't tell
you a really complicated closed formula
for dealing with two random variables in
an equal sign for now I'll tell you it's
more complicated than just doing
something like a CDF so if you didn't
have any access to the mathematics for
comparing two random variables man how
would you figure out the probability
that this random variable
is greater than that random
variable someone has an idea sampling
sampling yes we're computer scientist we
can always fall back on sampling when
everything get hard so here's what we're
going to do we're going to repeat 10,000
times and we're going to pull a random
variable for the Warriors from their
gaussian and we're going to pull a
random variable from the opponent from
their gaussian when you do stats. norm.
RVs it does this thing called sampling
it doesn't give you back the gaussian it
gives you back a pull from the gaussian
so will give you a number just and it'll
be governed by this Pro particular
probability distribution and we'll take
each of those numbers and we'll just
compare was that number greater than
zero in case We'll add one and we're
going to repeat 10,000 times and see how
often the pull from this gaussian was
greater than the pull from that gaussian
which is super cool um by sampling you
get 0.748 which according to this ELO
model uh is very very close to the
probability that the Warriors would win
that particular
game is there a better way I promise you
that we will tell you a better way oh
but this leads to one final extension
idea that I just think is so neat for
computer scientists to think about this
idea of a gaussian sample is so
interesting like how did how did python
do that right when you write this python
script so Random has a function called
gaus and if you get a mean and standard
deviation it gives you a pull from that
gaus and by a pull I mean like if you
set mean is equal to five and standard
is one if you run this 10 times you get
10 different
numbers are you curious how did python
do
that can I tell
you let's this the joy of being a
teacher I get to tell you when I want to
um here's the algorithm that python uses
and I love it because it is going to use
our Instinct of a CDF it's supposed to
be doing a pull where the likelihood is
governed by the probability density
function it's governed by this beautiful
equation here which we know is very hard
to
integrate here's the steps by step for
how it does it step
one you are going to pick a number
between 0 one uniformly computers are
quite good at that any number somebody
give me a number between 0 and
one I'm glad that you
chose that number so let's say you chose
like 08 what they do is they do the
inverse transfer of the uh CDF they say
what number would you put into the CD F
that would have given the number between
Z and one that you chose so you know
maybe you get um that this is 0.9 and
you say which value leads to a 0.9 and a
0.1 on in the CDF and it gives you maybe
a
1.2 the next time you choose a number
between 0 and one maybe you get
something like 3 and then when you ask
the inverse F question what input to F
function the CDF would I have had to
give to get 0.3
you get a different number let's say in
this case you get
.45 that's how it does it I've told you
the algorithm I haven't convinced you
that it's right and convincing you that
it's right I think is quite
interesting how much more likely is 1.2
the.45 we would like that relative
likelihood to be governed by the PDF
well if we think about how likely it is
we kind of want to think about like how
much vertical space is covered by
numbers close to 1.2 if you think about
how much vertical space is covered it
kind of has to do with what's the slope
of the CDF at that point if you think
about how much vertical space is covered
over here it kind of has to do with
what's the slope of the CDF at this
point and the slope of the CDF is going
to be the derivative of the
CDF and you know what the C derivative
of the CDF
is man the derivative of this thing is
that thing it's the PDF it's always the
PDF you derive the CDF you ask the slope
of the CDF at any point and you will get
the probability density function what a
beautiful thing so that is the
mathematics behind how this actually
works and now you know next time you
pull a Galaxy and you think oh we
learned about that cool algorithm it's
called inverse transform sampling if you
want to know um I did put this is not
something I want you to go over I did
put in a challenge if you guys want to
think about a challenge between now and
next Wednesday here's the thing to think
about otherwise just come back in next
minut we'll continue this wonderful
conversation have fantastic day I can't
wait to continue talking to you guys
about probability
cheers